[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings the City of
Minneapolis is paying nearly 9 million
dollars to settle two lawsuits alleging
more violent behavior from the officer
went on to kill George Floyd Derek
Chauvin is currently serving a 22-year
sentence for his role in Floyd's death
and a 21-year sentence for violating
Floyd's rights now body cam footage has
been released from two more violent
arrests back in 2017. amid allegations
his actions against Floyd were part of a
pattern Lily Luciano has more a warning
the footage is disturbing
this is
Zoya code was arrested in Minneapolis in
June of 2017 accused of attacking her
mother
newly released video shows Derek Chauvin
the same officer convicted for the
murder of George Floyd dragging and
carrying her while she's handcuffed her
arms outstretched behind her back
Chauvin slams code face first on the
ground and kneels on her neck for four
minutes and 42 seconds the same move he
used three years later for eight minutes
and 46 seconds with George Floyd
[Applause]
they were not the only ones another
plaintiff was John Pope Jr in 2017 he
was 14 years old
when Chauvin and other officers went
into his bedroom Pope pleaded with
officers alleging his mother was drunk
when she called law enforcement
former officer Chauvin and Alexander
walls violently wrestled Pope to the
ground Chauvin almost immediately
grabbed Pope by the neck and struck him
with his flashlight
then a chokehold
and a knee to the neck not for four or
eight but for 15 minutes
throughout their encounter Pope says the
experience is still with him even after
the 7.5 million dollar settlement now
he's in college studying criminal
justice in the hopes that he can bring
about change the system has a
that needs work to be done and
it's not going to get done just talking
about it it's going to get done with
Solutions two years after the killing of
George Floyd in 2022 a report by the
State's Department of Human Rights
concluded that the Minneapolis Police
Department creates a culture that
results in unnecessary escalation and or
excessive force during encounters we are
dealing with the ugly consequences
stemming from a systemic failure within
the Minneapolis Police Department legal
analyst Joe Tamborino says these
lawsuits show how those acknowledgments
came far too late if the Minneapolis
Police Department would have paid
attention to excessive use of force by
officers like Mr Chauvin back in 2017
and years before that then Mr Floyd
likely would not have been murdered
for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano
footage speaks for itself I mean you can
see it we can all see it with our own
eyes his actions and I think what that
gentleman just said if the Minneapolis
Police Department had been investigating
or at least been aware and if they were
aware had done something about this
George Floyd might be alive you also
wonder what can other departments across
the country learn from this and you look
at that body cam footage is that being
looked at in other departments whether
it's called for or not to look at video
like that and say we may have a problem
here when police do something on a call
and no one says anything about it it
becomes there's a sense that Derek
showman thought that was okay that was
standard practice and then it leads to
the conclusion we've all seen and
covered for years now yeah now he's
Behind Bars yeah